Wow most sports including football
involve athletes coming into direct
contact with each other
tennis keeps its competitors on opposite
sides of the net but there's a new
initiative that's using this sport to
bring people together and it's happening
where you'd least expect it at the
us-mexico border Jim Axelrod has the
story at this pop-up tennis court on the
Mexican US border thirteen year old Mary
Lou four do is practicing her forehand
in the shadow of a wall when I look
behind me I see the border wall and all
the wire they just put and that makes me
feel kind of sad she's part of an
after-school program that teaches tennis
in Nogales Arizona and on the other side
of the border in Nogales Mexico
Charlie Cutler is a tennis pro who
started the border youth tennis exchange
or biked throughout the year he brings a
hundred fifty kids from both sides of
the border together to play tennis
border communities are not scary places
border residents are the same as anyone
else that kid had learning to play
tennis in Mexico looks exactly the same
as a kid learn to play tennis in Arizona
Karolina Anita's is from Mexico
Esteban Alvarez is from Arizona I
probably would never have met this
person if I hadn't have done this event
so doing this event kind of gives me a
new perspective on life here they are
building a new friendship one volley at
a time we can be just friends
and we we are in enemies just because we
are from different places if the idea of
a wall is to separate these kids managed
to render it useless people across the
border I know different they're not bad
people we're all the same and we could
be friends and have fun score it love
love on this court and that means they
were all win for CBS this morning
Saturday
I'm Jim axilla yeah Lynette doesn't
divide him at unites them alrighty
ain't that the truth